LeLe premier ministre
BoBoris Johnson démissionne
dede son poste de chef
coconservateur, après le départ
enen cascade d'une cinquantaine
dede membres de son gouvernemen.
EÉric Albert,
nonotre collaborateur à Londres.
OnOn s'était bien dit hier que a
alallait se bousculer et
efeffectivement, il y a quelques
heheures à peine on était même s
ssûr qu'il allait démissionner
mmême si c'est démissionné du
ccôté de ses ministres.
- - Quel chaos absolu. Ça fait
trtrois ans que c'est un peu
chchaotique autour de lui en fat
etet finalement, il a annoncé
ququ'il allait démissionner. On
esest à cinq ans d'émission ce
mamatin le ministre ou secrétaie
d'd'État et en faire, il ne
trtrouvait plus de gens pour
reremplacer les ministres et ila
fifini par reconnaître qu'il étt
inincapable de continuer et il a
anannoncé qu'il allait
dédémissionner mais tant qu'il y
auaura des questions, est-ce qul
dédémissionne de son poste de
prpremier ministre tout de suite
ouou c'est seulement 200 postesu
PaParti conservateur, ou s'il
s's'accroche jusqu'à ce qu'il y
aiait une succession ou s'il ree
enencore. C'est pas clair. On st
papas ce qu'il va annoncer et
c'c'est dans deux heures à peu
prprès, il y avait des rumeurs e
dédémission et il reste encore n
cecertain nombre de questions.
OuOui, il va démissionner mais
dédémissionner de quoi, c'est ps
totout à fait clair.
- - On ne lui reproche pas mais
c'c'est le fait surtout qu'il mn
a a ses propres ministres qui vt
lele défendre à la radio et à la
tétélé tous les matins et c'està
quque le bris de confiance
susurvient
- - c'est exactement ça. La
coconnexion c'est défaite. Les
ministres n'en veulent pas pour
lele Brexit, la pandémie ou la
guguerre en Ukraine mais ce quia
fifini par la fin de la confiane
c'c'est que depuis six mois
mamaintenant, il y a cette
hihistoire anecdotique de petits
popots de départ pas dans le
coconfinement mais ce qui a
vrvraiment agacé les ministres e
ququ'il a menti et il a envoyé s
didifférents ministres et députs
dedevant les médias et aucune
rrègle n'a été donnée et devant
leles évidences, en reconnaît qe
leles règles n'avaient pas été
rerespectées. Il a reçu une amee
dede la police alors qu'il est n
poposte. Les ministres, les
dédéputés et les supporters qui
ététaient venus devant les médis
popour le défendre se sont sents
trtrahis. Ils ont dit des choses
ququi étaient fausses et ils se
sosont faits avoir. De nouveau
miministres est venu le défendre
lala semaine dernière et ils sot
ararrivés devant les médias en
didisant des choses fausses malé
eueux ils en ont eu marrent. Ils
onont dit ça suffit, ce premier
miministre n'est pas capable dee
papas mentir ni de maîtriser sa
cocommunication, en passent pour
dedes idiots.
- - Comment on va choisir les
chchefs à partir de maintenant?e
cacaucus, le conseil des minists
d'd'abord dans le triage des
cacandidats.
- - La façon dont ça se passe
c'c'est que c'est le Parti
coconservateur qui m'a désigné n
nonouveau leader, les députés vt
nonommer de candidats, qui vonte
dedevant les membres du parti
coconservateurs qui vont voter
pependant six semaines ou deux
momois environ pour avoir un
susuccesseur